hey everyone i hope you're enjoying next
21
welcome to our session on extending
infos to manage vm workloads in
on-premises environments
i'm jennifer smith director of product
management within google cloud anthos
i'm also joined today by my colleague
omar senior product manager for google
cloud anthos armor want to say hi to
everybody
hi everyone thank you for joining us
we're excited to show you some of the
cool things we've been working on over
the last couple of months
thanks armor we'll talk to you again
soon and like elmer said we're really
excited to share with you some of the
recent work we've been doing to help
enterprise customers further while they
navigate their hybrid and multi-cloud
applications
i know virtual presentations and
conferences have been our norm for
longer than we all might have imagined
so we've constructed our session today
as part talk and part due via a product
demo
so let's get going
customers are increasingly looking to
modernize
whether that modernization is in place
lift and shift or via containerization
an overwhelming majority of enterprises
have a hybrid and multi-cloud strategy
wanting to modernize with consistency
across all environments isn't just a
nicety it's crucial
and yet even with this increasing desire
to modernize only about 1 6 of
enterprise workloads are containerized
that leaves many millions of
non-containerized
vm-based workloads still in the data
center
how can we include these vms in
modernization efforts
we'll come back to that soon
let me start by providing a brief
overview of anthos
anthos is google's hybrid and
multi-cloud platform providing a
consistent operating system for
cloud-native deployments across all site
types whether that's on premises
at the edge or public cloud
it gives you all the tools you need for
consistent operations
service and policy management so that
you can build once and run anywhere
starting with container management it's
a reliable and efficient way to deploy
and run containers leveraging our
experience with google kubernetes engine
the industry leading container
management platform
on top of this sits the service
management layer it's a managed service
mesh offering to connect manage and
secure vms and containers this is based
on istio
and on top of that is the application
development layer
comprise comprising a wide selection of
production ready development solutions
and services from both google and our
partners all available through the
google cloud marketplace
the layers are flanked
on two sides
by policy management offering a central
place to manage configuration and
security policies across your fleet
using the power of kubernetes along with
get ops to implement an infrastructure
as code approach to your cloud native
network and on the other by operations
management offering an integrated
logging and monitoring service for
containers services and applications
there were a few really important
attributes we felt were essential to
building this new platform to help
customers with their hybrid and
multi-cloud applications
we wanted it to be open source
declarative in nature
developer friendly and extensible
because of this we chose kubernetes as
the basis of our anthos platform
and as we've been working with many
anthos customers on their modernization
journeys we've we've received some very
important feedback
customers have shared with us some of
their key challenges with modernization
starting with the simple fact that there
are many workloads that cannot be easily
or immediately moved to containers or
vms in the cloud
they've they also have organizational
skills and process gaps between cloud
native and traditional operations
their infra teams lack unified
management security and monitoring for
vms and containers
and their dev teams are constrained in
using modern application development
techniques and tools with traditional vm
workloads
delving a little bit deeper the root
causes of these challenges
are long multi-step provisioning
fragmented observability
manual compliance enforcement and an
expensive proprietary ecosystem
so what can we do
currently there are three cloud-centric
and one on-premises option for
modernizing existing vm applications
you can migrate virtual machines to
google cloud vms with migrate for
compute engine
you can lift and shift your entire
virtualization stack with google cloud
vmware engine
you can migrate your vm workloads to
containers on cloud with migrate for gke
or you could decide to modernize to
containers on premises with migrate for
anthos
we support all of these incremental vm
modernization strategies
but our customers want another option
they want a way to leave apps in vms
until and if they can be migrated while
gaining the same benefits of running
those vms on kubernetes and mapping
those vms using a consistent kubernetes
style approach to provisioning
configuration
monitoring and logging security and
optimization
so today
we're adding a new on-premises option
leveraging google's
leadership in kubernetes you can
modernize vm applications without
needing to containerize or move to cloud
right away and you can do this now with
anthos for vms
anthos for vms lets customers apply the
expertise they are building in running
and managing containers to their vm
environments
to build bridges of automation between
containers and vms and to reduce their
spending on vm platforms and management
tools
with this new option we provide the
flexibility of choice to modernize in a
way that best meets your business needs
so how does it actually come alive
we've created two adoption models
shiftable and attachable
in the shiftable case
vms run on anthems
in the attachable scenario we manage
other hypervisors vms within those
you can choose between the two
approaches or use them both
simultaneously
you get unified management declarative
deployment and policy enforcement for
your vms and your containers you bring a
cloud-like experience to your vms and
can leverage cloud-native services for
your vm workloads
moving to a bit of a deeper look at the
technologies that enable the shiftable
and the attachable approaches
first we see the runtime layer with
anthocvm runtime based on cubevert in
the shiftable scenario
in the attachable track we use vmware
vsphere
next we have network security and policy
via antho service mesh based on istio
and moving up the stack we have
kubernetes apis
and anathos config in policy management
at the top of the stack we have cloud
native capabilities and services such as
patch management databases and aiml
so with anthos for vms we help ease many
of the modernization challenges our
customers have shared with us
using kubernetes we are able to provide
fast secure infrastructure provisioning
unified operational visibility
automated compliance and cost reduction
pass it over to armor now ask him to
come back and join us and help explain
how we can get started and you can get
started with anthony's for vms and run
us through what the demo will look like
armor
thank you jennifer so the first step is
to
do a fit assessment
this is a tool that actually understands
your infrastructure and tries to
understand what is the right migration
or what is the right modernization
journey for your application
itrons is a standalone tool or you can
run it on top of an existing anthous
cluster if you're an anthous customer
and it does an assessment of the vm
workloads and it decides on a score that
tells you what is the right journey
whether it's shiftable you want to able
to migrate it to the anthous vm runtime
it's attachable connecting this vm to
anthus management layer or if it's
containerizable whether this vm is
containerizable or not and if a vm has
multiple options it lays it out too and
there is a fit score that also gives you
the effort and if there is any delta
that you need to address
for example in order to move from one
path to the other
from a workload perspective you download
the standalone tool you connect to
existing vcenter
it generates a local report that you
optionally you can upload to the cloud
for a detailed visualization or
historical view
we go to the next slide please this is
how the fit assessment report looks like
it provides you data center wide
readiness
as i mentioned actionable vm level
suggestions roi analysis and risk
metrics to every migration
and now next
we have a demo and we're very excited to
show you that demo we've been working on
some of these technologies for a couple
of months
so the just to describe the demo the
first part of the demo talks about the
discovery and fit assessment using the
mfit tool that we just mentioned
and then we're going to showcase two
scenarios of shiftable vm and attachable
vm that have been migrated or attached
and then for day two we're going to talk
about management uh from cloud
operations and those configuration
management and anthro service mesh
so with that let's move on to the demo
all right we're now ready for a quick
demo of anthos for vms
here we see the anthus landing page
this is the central interface where you
can view your registered antes clusters
monitor your services with antiservice
mesh
or manage legacy workloads with anthos
for vm's new vm management capabilities
the critically important first step when
using anthrax for vms is to run a fit
assessment on your legacy vmware
environment determine which vms can be
easily containerized shifted or attached
answers for vm's fit assessment tooling
quickly scans your vmware environment
and collects application hardware
networking and storage metadata related
to each vmware vm to systematically
determine which category belongs to
once its assessment is completed
the results are displayed in a report it
explains each recommendation in detail
okay now with that explanation out of
the way let's run a fit assessment and
see the results
here we go open terminal as anthony's
fit assessment tool installed on
after we run a single command and
authenticate our vmware environment
we'll see the assessment tool start to
rapidly scan through over 2000 vms
then uploads results to the google cloud
console
once the report has been generated
we see that we've assessed 2077 vms
15 of them were categorized as being
excellent candidates to attach to anthos
for vms with an agent
and the rest were great candidates to be
hosted on kubernetes using cooper
in particular we see detailed results
for three legacy vms
a front end a back end and a transaction
service
we'll examine a few results in more
depth
and later on the demo we'll use
anthocyanums to both shift and attach
these legacy vms to anthis's modern
kubernetes based control plane
now open the result for legacy front
service
we see that it has been categorized as
shift candidate due to its q vert
compatible application profile
open the result for the legacy
transaction service
we see that it has been categorized in
attach candidate due to the fact it
requires multiple network interfaces
okay
now it's time to generate the migration
artifacts that answers for vms were used
to take control these legacy vms
here we see a migration job called demo1
is already underway
clicking on create migration will show
us the prompt that was used to create
this job
by filling in just a few values
such as migration source
operating system type for the source vms
and the desired output for migration
like containerize or convert to a qvert
vm
one can easily create a vm migration job
examining our in-progress migration job
more closely
we can see it is currently preparing
some vm manager artifacts
switching back to the google cloud
console we see an empty table
after clicking the refresh button we see
that our anthous cluster now contains
the new qvert and istio custom resources
that are just created by analyst config
manager
we navigate to the workloads tab
we can see that the kubernetes pods
associated with the two legacy vms that
we shipped to cubert are now running as
well
clicking on one of these workloads
takes us to an overview page that shows
real-time metrics and events
clicking on the operations button
opens a side panel displays tons of
additional information
like granular metrics and logs
specifically designed to assess
application reliability
next we shift your focus to the answer
vm service mesh
here we see the entire service topology
of our example application
our example app generates client traffic
that is sent to a modern containerized
front-end service
this front-end service in turn sends
requests to a few other modern apis in
our three shifted and attached legacy
vms
the phone service is highly available
it sits behind a load balancer which
spreads traffic across five service
replicas
requests to the modern front end
made to a few particular endpoints are
automatically routed to the legacy
shifted from it
similarly
the modern frontend also routes a few
specific api calls to the legacy shifted
back-end service
the legacy attached transaction service
is called both by the shifted back-end
service and number of other modern apis
double-clicking on the shifted back-end
service
takes us to a detailed view of its local
service topology
where we can see info on its current
performance in research utilization
and lots of other stuff
more importantly
now that our legacy vm is management
we can now use anthos observability
tooling to make the old app awesome
to demonstrate this we're going to go
ahead and create an slo
ak a service level objective
first we select an availability based
sli
here we'll set our compliance period to
one week
and our performance goal to 99.5
availability
finally we'll click create
next we'll add an alert to our slo
here we'll just select all the default
settings
then add a short message
awesome we just sprinkled some google
sre magic on our legacy application
and now we've reached the end of our
demo
we've seen how antlers for vms can be
used to consistently manage legacy
applications using kubernetes
awesomeness
and slick google tooling enjoy
we hope you like the demo and with that
i'll hand it over to jennifer to tell us
how we can learn more about and through
vms
thanks armor thanks for sharing how our
customers can get started with anthos
for vms like umer said we would love to
work with you as well
anthos for vms is currently in preview
and we are working with a group of
customers as our design partners if
you're interested in our preview or
learning more please contact us at this
email
we would really love to talk some more
thank you very much have a great day and
enjoy the rest of next 21